au mois de mai de l'année dernière
un soir je suis rentré et puis j'ai plus
de meubles plus de femmes plus d'enfants
et depuis donc je suis en instance de
divorce
d'abord j'ai pas compris qu'ils étaient
surpris mais apparemment si elle a
demandé le divorce et que selon ces
motifs elle sait qu'elle étouffe
bon c'est quelque chose que je peux
comprendre j'admets
qu'une femme ou un homme décide à un
moment donné de se séparer mais j'aurais
préféré qu'il y ait eu un dialogue
auparavant et que je ne sois pas dans la
situation de surprise totale et dans la
situation actuelle je me suis trouvée
vous n'avez pas pressenti ça il n'y a
pas eu des petites
sonnette d'alarmé ce n'est effectivement
il ya eu certainement eu des sonnettes
mais avant qu'on arrive dans la
situation précise je crois que on est
sûr pour autant de sonnettes quelqu'un
faisait comme travailleur henry faisait
le même métier que moi et laitages
embrayage aussi et il m'est revenu me
permettait ce que puisse rester à la
maison
donc elle est restée veut un an et demi
à s'occuper de l'enfant elle le désire à
ça coûte et inconsciemment je crois
qu'elle aurait préféré travailler et la
preuve puisque ces motifs c'est que
déclare qu'elle étouffe et je crois que
j'aurais préféré reprendre son travail
un mois ou deux mois ensuite après
l'accouchement
pourquoi vous venez ici et de préférence
avec votre fils parce que c'est un
endroit masculin où on est en train mais
comme j'ai un fils qui est un garçon bas
pour lui c'est une bonne chose parce que
je suis pas en contact avec toutes les
lesbiennes les [ __ ] et les [ __ ] du
mlf qui ne pensent qu'à toucher des
pensions alimentaires à des prestations
compensatoires
après avoir filé a pris les enfants en
otage par le biais des xi à tola du
palais de justice
cette plaisanterie dure depuis plus de
deux ans puisque j'ai reçu une
ordonnance exactement de justice le 1er
décembre 1980 me sommant de déguerpir de
chez moi on appelle ça quitter les lieux
le 1er décembre 1980 le jour même dire
sans préavis
ce qui est absolument scandaleux et je
me suis retrouvé mis à la porte comme ça
par la police et par un huissier avec
uniquement ce qu'on appelle mes effets
personnels et alors j'étais obligé
d'atterrir au domicile de ma mère car
par chance elle avait un appartement à
paris dont ça se fait qu'elle a demandé
le divorce a demandé le divorce au bout
de quinze 15 ans de mariage parce que
d'une part j'avais des difficultés
professionnelles en ce sens que je peux
surtout au chômage quelles étaient leurs
intentions avant j'étais ingénieur
commercial en bâtiment et
je pense que en tant que chômeurs sont
un fardeau pour elle et que le divorce
est un excellent moyen de se débarrasser
de moi si je puis dire
vous avez la sensation d'avoir été un
bon mari je n'ai pas eu la prétention et
havas était un époux parfait mais j'ai
la prétention d'avoir été un époux qui
ne lui a pas gâcher sa vie qui ne l'a
pas emmerdé comme on dit je n'ai jamais
cherché à la mettre à la porte je n'ai
pas cherché à lui prendre mon fils je
n'ai pas cherché à la priver d'argent
quand j'avais de l'argent
je n'ai pas cherché à l'empêcher de
partir en vacances elle alors qu'elle
partait trois mois par an aux vacances
donc j'estime que c'était quand même une
vie assez tranquille et vous qu'elle
vous ai fait ça qu'elle vous ai foutu à
la porte et tout ça vous fait mal
bah bien sûr parce que moralement
j'estime que c'est absolument odieux a
pas quinze heures du mariage demeure
traité comme un chien
je m'attendais pas du tout au bout de
quinze ans de mariage d'être traité
comme un paria ou un pestiféré sais
quelle atmosphère au palais de justice
on veut c'est plutôt la justice à la
chaîne
vous savez les femmes arrivent là dedans
en terrain conquis ils ont des grands
sourires jusqu'aux oreilles et vous
savez que les carottes sont cuites al
avance il n'y a pas du tout d'égalité
parental le père nullement uniquement
considéré comme un pourvoyeur de fonds
bons qu'à payer
et puis après on le met à la rue on
prend les enfants même des fois certains
perdent leur guise en fait ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que même les juges
à faire preuve matrimoniale sans avoir
vu les enfants des fois neil père se
permettent de supprimer même ce qu'on
appelle le droit de visite
vous pouvez retrouver à ne plus voir ou
revoir votre enfant à partir d'une
audience dite de conciliation qui dure
des fois pas plus de cinq minutes
donc vous avez combien d'enfants moi
j'en ai qu'un heureusement il est à 16
ans maintenant et disons que je vais
arriver au bout du rouleau quand il aura
la majorité
mais je plains beaucoup les pères qui
ont des enfants en bas âge et qui se
retrouvent vie qui lui dit qu'est ce que
vous pensez des statistiques qui annonce
que c'est il ya plus de femmes que
d'hommes qui demande de divorce en
france
je suis sûr que c'est vrai parfum ça
correspond pour moi à quelque chose de
vécu et que je vois aussi bien dans ma
vie que dans mon entourage
aujourd'hui c'est les femmes qui se
barre quand une relation casse s'est
presque jamais l'homme qui s'en va c'est
la femme qui s'en va j'ai observé ça sur
des dizaines de cas autour de moi ou
aussi
dans ma vie propre je veux dire même
quand sa situation matérielle de la
femme se dégradent des suites de ça ça
fait rien on joue aujourd'hui je crois
que c'est les femmes qui partent et
pourquoi
peut-être peut-être parce que les hommes
acceptent plus facilement les compromis
jeu satisfont de situation pas très net
peut-être parce qu'il ya une certaine
lâcheté chez les hommes et peut-être
aussi parce qu'aujourd'hui les femmes
sont beaucoup plus beaucoup plus active
par rapport à leurs désirs bon il m'est
arrivé d'aller à une fête avec avec une
fille avec qui j'étais
et puis au milieu de la soirée elle me
dit il ya un mec qui me plaît là j'ai
envie de me taper alors tu m'excuses tu
rentres tu rentres sans moi on verra
demain
moi je trouve que c'est difficile à
vivre et je trouve en plus que jamais
jamais je ne me suis permis de faire ça
de le dire de le faire je connais aucun
mec qui les fait quoi qu'on dise je
pense pas que jamais les les hommes se
soit permis de faire des trucs comme ça
je trouve un peu dur à avaler que parce
que les femmes ont ce soit sont battus
pour leur indépendance ils ont conquis
leur indépendance
elle s'autorise à traiter les mecs de la
sorte et je dois dire que pour un homme
ça pose de gros problèmes
moi ça me perturbe profondément de
quelle manière
c'est une manière de se sentir tellement
n'y est tellement remis en cause
tellement
c'est comme si on n'était pas là c'est
comme si on n'existait plus mois après
je ne peux pas je peux pas faire l'amour
c'est à dire moi c'est un truc qui me
rend impuissant
pendant un mois deux mois trois mois
c'est dur c'est vraiment dur à avaler
vous avez rencontré votre ferme à quel
âge
j'avais
j'ai 30 ans pas souvenu est un must à
chamrousse
présent cause de vacances au mois de
et comment s'est passée la rencontre et
vous êtes management en jeu marié
trois ans après le service militaire et
après le service
[Musique]
pourquoi vous l'avez cousin lahjar de la
vie chatel ge pour beaucoup c'était
je viens de lire une raison apparemment
on s'entendait bien avec bâle en bonne
entente
vous étiez amoureux d'elle weight
watchers été bien accepté dans la
famille j'étais bien accepté dans la
sienne il y avait pas de problème mais
vous avez un désir de vous marier
oui pourquoi pour créer une famille
avoir des enfants et vous avez eu
premier enfant quand même temps après
s'est marié en 74 on l'a eu en soixante
seize lente et 176 il était voulue oui
c'est une petite fille britt fille
stéphanie oui lille deuxième enfant j'ai
mon franc est venu en 78 voulu aussi
voulu o'shea vous entendiez bien avant
l'arrêt votre femme n'y avait pas de
problème quand est-ce que certains
dansaient les problèmes 79 pourquoi vous
voulez changer changer de vie
ce qui est peut-être trop monotone vous
même vous souffriez de cette vie
conjugale lien avec des trajets remis au
congrès un moment donné je me suis
aperçu que l avait eu quelqu'un entre
stéphanie et christian alors je vais
demander pourquoi la propulsant répondre
pourquoi alors là déjà il y avait un
doute ils puis après avec d'autres
collègues de son bureau
je savais qu'elle avait eu des rapports
alors un peu volage quoi vous ne vous
êtes jamais posé la question de vous
dire par exemple c'est peut-être moi qui
n'arrive pas tellement la rendre
heureuse
des choses comme ça
maka voyez vous je me posais pour à
cette question maintenant je me la pose
mais je pense pas que ça tu n'y penses
pas que cela n'ait de la physique mans
est heureuse avec vous je crois oui oui
mais ce que m'a jamais fait de reprocher
dessus vous avez des amants des
collectes de travail déjà que je
connaissais j'avais vu et puis le
dernier à lille et paris travaillent pro
chez renault c'est le divorce était
autour de qui à la fin c'était à son
tour exclusif en à sa main les femmes en
changer à votre avis pourquoi comment ça
s'est passé elles ont changé parce que
elles vont travailler au dehors comme on
dit maintenant on a fabriqué des crèches
des maternelles qui permettent de
laisser les gosses disons à d'autres
donc elles ont voulu travailler pour
comme ils disent se libérer ou avoir
davantage sur le plan financier
donc inévitablement elles sont
sollicitées par des collègues de travail
qui sont souvent masculin en général et
le mari de père se retrouve en
concurrence avec ces hommes là et alors
naturellement le fait qu'elles ont des
revenus qu'elle n'avait pas auparavant
puisque avant le disait leur mari de
leur donner de l'argent à leurs patins
n'ont plus besoin de lui pour ça excepté
dans diverses naturellement eh bien
elles peuvent s'acheter de la toilette
se faire des soins de beauté et puis
tous la bombe et créer un environnement
au travail disons qu'ils sollicitent les
hommes qui l'entourent
et puis de plus comme la pilule
maintenant qui leur permet de baiser
sans risque
eh bien on peut faire cocu son mari
comme on veut sans aucun sens aucun
inconvénient et c'est l'une des raisons
pour laquelle à mon avis on voit la
progression du diversifier le père ou le
mari est en concurrence avec l'extérieur
ce qui n'était pas le cas avant lorsque
la femme est au foyer est ce que vous
pensez des féministes
e
j'hésite papa parce que je me dérobe
parce que c'est vraiment une question
très difficile
je crois que ça a été un bon d'abord
s'agit pas de dire de dire qu on est
pour ou qu'on est contre ça c'est un
mouvement historique au même titre que
les que l'émancipation du prolétariat ou
les socialistes il y avait une situation
d'oppression et d'injustice
il ya eu une révolte c'est légitime
c'est normal comme toute révolte
elle a mis du temps aussi à ceux à se
trouver et elle a entraîné beaucoup
d'excès on peut regretter les excès la
révolution française était nécessaire
elle a entraîné aussi beaucoup d'excès
on peut pas au nom des excès remettre en
cause la révolution française bon donc
le féminisme c'est une réalité
historique
il faut vivre avec à la grande époque du
mouvement féministe les femmes insisté
pour payer pour partager parce que
c'était une manière de manifester leur
égalité et de justement de refuser le
rapport de domination du mec qui paye je
trouve que c'était normal logique et
cohérent et aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe je ne je vois plus jamais de nanas
qui propose simplement de payer au
restaurant au moment où l'addition
arrive elle regarde ailleurs le regard
se perd délicieusement au ciel mais
l'addition c'est question matérielle
elle n'existe plus alors là je trouve
qu'il ya une petite abus parce que
les filles autonome aujourd'hui joue sur
les deux tableaux
il n'est pas question qu'elle remette en
cause leur liberté et leur autonomie
mais elles veulent en même temps
profiter de tous les avantages du statut
traditionnel d'autrefois de la femme
courtisée servi femme-fleur femme-objet
adulé mais mais en même temps il n'est
pas question pour elles de renoncer à un
centimètre de leur territoire ou de leur
indépendance pour autant c'est à dire ça
les empêche pas ça les empêche pas de
vous balancer une baffe dans la gueule
cinq minutes après alors je trouve que
là c'est pas cohérent donc jamais de
partage dans un restaurant que c'est
très rare
c'est vraiment très rare les week-ends
je dirais en tout c'est toujours moi qui
paye là est la question se pose même pas
c'est automatique
elle est arrivée une anecdote que je
trouve vraiment significatif ça n'est
qu'une anecdote pour une copine le
téléphone un soir dijon avec des amis au
restaurant vient nous rejoindre
en fait moi j'avais déjà mangé j'y vais
comme ça parce que pour prendre un pot
l'addition arrive et la fille dit c'est
les braguettes qui paye ta d'autorité
sans même nous consulter sans même qu'on
ait pu éventuellement avoir le geste
d'invités n'en sait alors c'est très
révélateur parce que c'est la taxe il
faut payer
voilà on est on est des porte-monnaie
ambulant si tu veux sortir avec une nana
il faut payer c'est c'est devenu ma main
rapports d'utilisation maintenant de
manipulation elle travaille elle gagne
autant que nous mais leur salaire c'est
de l'argent de poche les sorties les
loisirs s'est entièrement financé par
les mecs cette servante d'exploitation
finalement parce que on veut même pas
avoir le le plaisir de
d'invités non on est on est mis à la
taxe ou est ce que les femmes prennent
leurs idées il ya dans les magazines
féminins pour la plupart jeu puisque
entre les recettes de cuisine et et
soins de beauté maintenant leur donne ce
qu'on appelle des conseils juridiques où
ils apprennent que demande en divorce
pas de problèmes sont tous les droits la
garde de l'enfant puissance du domicile
de mobilier et puis des pensions parce
que pension alimentaire prestation
compensatoire et autres
plaisir et
moi pas seulement quand j'ai pris
conseil auprès d'avocats je me suis
aperçu que j'avais autant aucun droit je
n'étais uniquement considéré comme un
banquier
est-ce que vous pensez que votre femme
est heureuse maintenant maintenant
l'heure actuelle will et terreuse à la
sa vie tranquille n'a pas de contrainte
elle vit avec un homme et chacun son
appartement il son livre n'a pas
d'enfant et les personnes avant l'été
avec moi avec deux enfants elle n'est
pas libre avec vous avant elle va être
contrainte il fallait rentrer à l'heure
pour est à la maison pour s'occuper de
la maison pour s'occuper des enfants
tandis que maintenant elle fait ce
qu'elle veut quand elle veut
après son passage chez elle je ne veux
pas en fait pour moi le malaise masculin
ces stars enfin la principale source du
malaise masculin c'est ça parce que je
crois qu'il ya un malaise c'est que on
ne sait pas très bien comment il faut
faire
on ne sait pas ce qu'on nous demande et
je crois que en fait les femmes nous
demandent des choses très
contradictoires
comme quoi comme de respecter
entièrement leur autonomie et leur
indépendance parce qu'elles se sont
chèrement battu pour pour les acquérir
et en même temps elles ont re découvert
ce sas et il ya depuis quelques années
qu'elle souhaitait quand même avoir en
face d'elles des hommes des vrais comme
elles disent c'est à dire des mecs sur
qui on puisse s'appuyer qui remplissent
encore une fonction assez traditionnel
d'hommes protecteur fort sûr de lui mais
alors il ya des jours où il faut être
presque absent parce qu'elles ont envie
de vivre leur vie autonome et elles
n'ont pas envie de vous voir
et puis le lendemain il faudrait être là
avec une épaule solide des carrés sur
laquelle elles puissent poser leur tête
et puis leur jouer du violon parce
qu'elles ont envie ce jour là de jouer
la petite fille
seulement il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de
mode d'emploi on sait pas on sait pas
quel jour il faut être le mec et quel
jour il faut être plus
discret et et puis c'est difficile
d'être les deux en même temps est ce que
les hommes ne vendent pas la même chose
aux femmes inversement
moi je crois pas que ma demande à
l'égard des femmes échangé ni qu'elle
soit très compliqué je suis resté à
celle assez traditionnel au fond je
pense pas qu'elle est que les mecs
soient tellement tellement compliqué au
difficile à comprendre
fermez kinésithérapeute à travailler à
mi temps
elle s'occupait d'eux reste du temps de
mon fils et des travaux ménagers en
particulier et moi je vais travailler au
dehors et comme beaucoup d'hommes jeu
partait le matin rentrait le soir
qu'est ce que vous pensez des sommes
justement qui participe aux tâches
ménagères mais à écouter cette petite
nouvelle génération qu'on appelle les
papas poules où les nouveaux pères
je crois qu'en effet dans les nouvelles
générations d'hommes qui ont dans les 20
30 ans c'est une nouvelle mode
personnellement je n'étais pas de cette
génération ce n'était pas de cette fois
puisque j'ai 45 ans enfin l'homme qui
passe ce qui fait le ménage ou qui est
la serpillière comme vous dites dans le
foyer je pense que ça se retourne à plus
ou moins long terme contre eux parce que
je pense que dans le ménage est une
question de rapport de force
et lorsque l'homme veut trop renoncer à
sa masculinité
eh bien je pense que les femmes prennent
conscience de leur force et que à ce
moment là il s'établit un rapport de
faiblesse au détriment de l'homme qui à
long terme se retourne contre lui et
dans les nouvelles générations nous que
l'on appelle les papas poules et le
nouveau père il ya beaucoup de divorces
il en a plus que dans les anciennes
puisqu'elle si l'on prend les
statistiques du divorce
voyez un accroissement continu elle dans
les nouvelles générations et non pas
dans les anciens c'est quoi la muscu la
masculinité mais bien la minuscule
l'unité c'est de rester un homme est de
ne pas avoir honte et d'être fier d'être
un homme
c'est noir à
accepter l'abaissement de sa condition
d'homme comme beaucoup de féministes
s'amuse à le faire alors que les femmes
ont des avantages comme les hommes ont
aussi des avantages mais ne pas chercher
à inverser les rôles je suis très
paresseux alors dans la mesure où elles
manifestent la mesure où elle s'occupe
des choses je laisse faire parce que je
suis paresseux mais si je sens qu'il ya
un problème est que cette distribution
des tâches
le huit pays ou qu'elle trouve que c'est
pas normal
et à ce moment je fais les choses m'ont
paru bons il faut qu'on en parle qu'on
en discute mois au fond naturellement je
préfère poser mon cul quelque part et
puis laisser faire les choses je n'aime
pas faire la vaisselle j'aime pas faire
le ménage mais je ne considère pas que
ce soit non plus le rôle de ma copine ça
ne me dérange pas que le ménage soit pas
fait pendant trois mois ou clavet scène
soit pas fait pendant quinze jours et si
elle me demande de le faire je le fais
c'est une vie qui vous plaît je n'ai pas
choisi il faut si nous ait choisis
garder vos enfants joliment mes enfants
s'est dit sûr mais je veux dire la
double journée de travail que ça vous
donne ça veut c'est moins de pleins pour
ça que ne pas les avoir dans wii est
dans une position qui sont beaucoup de
femmes au sila qui gardent leurs enfants
rim travaille pas disons que les choses
se sont compliquées même gâtés puisque
ma femme s'est amusé à me refuser ce
qu'on appelle le droit de visite et à ce
moment là j'ai cru disons que sur le
plan légal les choses pouvaient se
passer disons le cours n'a bleus mentir
vous allez à la police je vous fait une
déclaration de non représentation
d'enfant alors que l'ordonnancé puis de
là bas la police vous répond il vaut
mieux pas se déplacer parce que ça va
traumatiser l'enfant alors là vous vous
demandez si vous êtes vraiment le perdre
votre enfant parce que c'est incroyable
que la police se déplace pour vous
mettre à la porte et qu'elle ne se
déplace pas pour vous faire voir votre
boss et puis de là ma femme sachant que
tous les droits bon ben là à fait comme
beaucoup de femmes aiment s'amuser m ont
refusé devant mon fils pendant 3 4
points
j'ai utilisé comme beaucoup de perles
des moyens qui ne sont pas très
catholique si on veut mais j'ai tapé
dans la porte j'ai fait un petit peu de
scandales dans la maison et puis j'ai
attrapé mon gars c'est quand il sortait
de l'école pour leurs marques avec moi
pas d'autre solution et j'ai vu tout de
suite que mon fils était comme un otage
et que j'avais pas d'autre moyen que de
droit court si on peut dire à la force
pour avoir mon fils quand j'avais le
droit de voir ce que dix ans qu'on
appelle
pourquoi vous reprocher quelque chose de
l'éducation de votre région bien sûr la
forme d'éducation que de ma femme mon
fils et qui utilisons une éducation trop
féminine c'est à dire que on l'emmène le
dimanche au plus pour acheter des
poupées j'estime qu'un garçon de 16 ans
d'autres activités de loisirs que celle
d'aller voir des poupées chez les
antiquaires le dimanche alors quand il
était avec moi et mon beau match de foot
du parc des princes on va au bout les
nombreux fous on va jouer au flipper on
va dans dans des lieux disons masculin
dans des cafés ou dans les lieux disons
chivu s'est passé les antiques et
acheter des poupées comme ça c'est que
l'image virile ça fonctionne comme ça
car bien sûr mois les rapports avec mon
fils n'est pas de se tenir au bras
dessus bras dessous comme le fait ma
femme avec mon fils par exemple le soir
quand ils regardent la télé vous l'idée
de venir s'asseoir à côté d'elle dans
les livres regarder la télé moi je n'ai
jamais pris mon fils à côté de moi pour
regarder la télé mais quand il y avait
quelque chose d'intéressant mais cette
date et rabat excusez moi s'est plaint
des rapports de tendresse à s'est
rapidement senti un garçon de 16 ans qui
arrive à l'adolescence n'a plus besoin
de la tendresse d'une maman il a surtout
de besoin de la tendresse d'une autre
jeune fille comme lui je crois et c'est
une meilleure façon de l'élever à mon
avis c'est ma façon de vouloir les
levées en tant qu'homme savoir je
préférais qu'il soit un dragueur qu'un
fils qui soit au bras de sa mère chez
les antiquaires des puces à sa fin pour
choisir des poupées pensait pas grâce à
l'évolution des femmes les hommes vont
changer dans le sang à mieux je veux
dire par là il y aura moins
d'agressivité et de recherche de
domination sur l'autre c'est peut-être
un peu idéaliste je crois je sais je
crois que j'y crois pas de toute façon
on peut gagner que dans une relation
amoureuse et un rapport de force
alors ce rapport de force peut évoluer
peut devenir fluctuant c'est à dire qu'à
un coup s'est dit en faveur de du mec un
cool et en faveur de la nana ou à
l'intérieur d'un même couple
il peut se renverser tous les mois ou
tous où tous les jours mais il ya
toujours une
une recherche de domination le l'égalité
c'est un idéal on y temps mais en fait
ça n'existe pas vous pensez que la
domination et la voix de son côté a soit
dominante de binaire oui cette
conclusion très pessimiste est un peu
amer mais finalement oui oui parce que à
vouloir ne pas dominer tout à l'heure
vous me demandiez ce que je pensais des
féministes bombe pendant longtemps
j'étais en accord avec les féministes
donc je m'écrase et je me suis je me
suis castrés gg réprimer mais désire je
me suis fait dominer par conviction
idéologique
j'en ai pas été très heureux et ça a pas
donné de très bons résultats et
aujourd'hui quand je leur parle de ça
avec les filles avec qui j'étais à
l'époque elles me disent qu au fond
c'était pas c'était parce qu'elle aurait
souhaité qu'elle aurait voulu que je
sois quand même un homme alors je
parlais tout à l'heure de deux demandes
contradictoires l'une des raisons de mon
malaise c'est quand on me demande des
choses très difficiles à concilier
faut être un mec en même temps il faut
respecter la revendication féministe de
l'autre comment on comment vous
concilier ça moi je sais pas
un belge et deux en bronze à dire les
fameux actuellement comme les femmes
considèrent les hommes c'est à dire
comme un objet de plaisir et je ne
cherche pas du tout avant barras et
d'une femme dans la vie quotidienne pour
me retrouver avec les ennuis auxquels
j'ai été confronté par le divorce dans
le cadre du mariage
malheureusement on s'aperçoit que avec
des [ __ ] on aura moins d'ennuis qu'avec
une femme qui ne l'est pas est bon et la
tendresse latin mais latendresse
maintenant je pense que on est entré
dans la société de consommation où la
consommation physique passe avant dans
la tendresse et c'est ce que les femmes
peut-être tendance à rechercher essai
sud on se contente je crois aussi
beaucoup d'hommes
je pense qu'à long terme ça se
retournera contre les femmes parce que
beaucoup d'hommes match dans 10 g koné
untel ou untel qui était mariée kate
divorcée qui se retrouvent disons dans
le pétrin moi personnellement je viens à
la colle ou en concubinage est comme ça
je prends aucun risque en série et je
pense que le mariage c'est d'unir
exemple qu'il ya deux mois de mariage
qui donne à nos parents et moi de
naissance est due à cette crainte que
commence à voir les hommes de cette
façon de voir mes dessins mais vous
pensez pas que la pilule élevé ges un
programme comme un bélier pour les
femmes
oui mais qu'ont les femmes et les invite
à corps mais pour les hommes aussi
mais je veux dire si c'est pour se
retrouver en concurrence continuellement
avec d'autres hommes
il est bien évident qu'on ne dira plus
ma femme nous on dira notre femme qu'est
ce que vous pensez de la contraception
féminine la plus grande révolution du
20e siècle
non peut-être plus la plus grande
révolution de de ces deux depuis 2000
ans puisque l'électricité je n'irai je
crois qu'on n'a pas fini d'en mesurer
les conséquences
tout ce dont on parle le malaise des
hommes émancipation des femmes tout ça
c'est lié à la contraception en fait en
grande partie et ça va accoucher d'une
société différente
actuellement on est dans les
balbutiements on peut dire pas de chance
pour nous parce que on est à cheval sur
deux mondes donc on n'est pas à l'aise
je serais curieux de voir à quoi
ressemblera le monde dans 100 ans
tout aura changé et ça c'est l'une des
choses avec la révolution
technologique qui qui accouchera la
société de demain
[Musique]